welcome to this video playing Mikolka
1985 and i always forget what he's
playing what kind of opening does he
play Queens Indian what was the last
came hmm what did we do did I had this
opening against him earlier i'm kind of
curious not sure yeah i had this this in
in an earlier game not me not today or
anything but not know long while ago
he's very cool about his those night
maneuvers they're funny yeah nyesha one
age three it's an interesting idea that
I saw once not sure that was the right
moment for for that or or not but looks
kind of active this position can I go
interesting maybe 95 here then we fought
voice is wrong you might have c5 now 97
a threat but not after this move anymore
so if or here right that was my idea if
I go 97 now this is not doing anything
this God bishops is 60 not doing
anything as 2 to positive let's say okay
I'm thinking I should go back there with
the bishop his glory days are over
anushree yeah so he's really saying to
me that this is an exposed piece maybe
it is maybe it is
just you three here or hmm what do I go
back with the noid simply let's go back
I think 95 was probably wrong idea
okay so night be five it's no problem it
says okay that's it's very easy to
believe actually what about you for
would've come on let's open this up I'm
better developed so let's open the pod
oh shut up maybe it just trades down the
whole board but I think I should have
done that earlier I mean not play 95 but
no more um go for you for in a more
straightforward way oh interesting I
thought you might go see mc4
what about this now look to d7 Quincy 6
hmm
ok anyway it's no tech to cure 95 maybe
this is a tactic I can take a for then
Bishop c6 okay
I got many simplifications now
interesting that's the interesting move
hmm
and before I still hanging okay let's do
this let's try to be quickly i can go 94
actually that was a silly move they can
play 94 without any problem okay maybe
maybe maybe not so easy I have 96
since okay again I think it should be ok
and night on c4 is pretty good what am I
playing kingi to f3 this kind of setup
and some end games ok have three only if
I need to but I you can go rook f8f give
look after f6 rook f6 rookie to look F
for threatening Bishop takes a for that
wins I'm upon gathered wins the pot I
think that's good okay this is probably
similar No wow that's good weakening the
position there I don't know can you
check grab that poor now I really don't
understand what is doing him yeah I fb3
I mean it's not not a big deal though
checking me a first even check
take this now and yeah wonder that time
warhammer i can i can take all the ones
actually 92 is not possible maybe i can
go Knight a5 here in fact 496 but maybe
this is just a stupid idea you always
win with y'all later probably that
wasn't the greatest idea ever
they're not good technical play but I
think it's still all right
night is stopping the porn and I don't
need much more help anyporn would do the
job check okay let's let's push this
home black resigns he had a great
position he just has to play a look at
six here look at six looking for that
line that i mentioned rue kev here
rookie to have to I guess Andrew care
for I did Mona g4s detect and he
threatening Bishop f2 yeah I really
played this badly he got a got a very
nice position down Route 27 and until i
bungled this up step by step rook c8 and
he's got the two bishops I have to be
very careful now went with this but now
he's very active this chair now be three
is a bit better but okay I i saw that
later we hear so we have six that this
happens and now though I mean he can
still get six maybe I should have taken
h5 but and the f5 is really bad I mean
this is just a bad idea check this was
also not helpful yeah yeah I'm
completely completely winning check
probably not doing the best job of a
technical wise but at least the
computers is always giving me a pretty
big advance
advantage so I didn't dindori screw it
up it wasn't it only wasn't the cleanest
cleanest possible way okay well thanks
for watching